[Music]
your fans and you have a lot of them are
obsessed with turning with turning your
last name bana into banana I'm obsessed
with it and they're just entire websites
that are filled with images of you and
bananas where they've turned you time
and time again what is banana bread yeah
it's well I'm not offended I love
bananas I ate a load of bananas all the
time in fact I do I'm and I like banana
bread so I'm not complaining I love a
banana okay why do they not no one ever
takes there's no image of you eating a
banana they just out taking bananas and
superimposing them onto your photograph
no one has ever photographed me eating a
banana this is the one pep shot I've
managed to avoid is bana eating a banana
I guess until tonight just eat this
banana
[Applause]
okay I feel this is gonna yeah you'll
see this is gonna be this is gonna make
your fans so happy you're okay with this
I'm absolutely fine I feel like after
the Ranga joke I really had my alright
notice that I yeah that's not the way to
do it oh you break it off that's my
usual way Andy what's your stuff you
don't break you're not a break-off guy
I usually peel the whole thing and then
hold it you know actually banana itself
for how long do you eat it
I throw the peel away and then I eat the
banana do you and she just knew you made
it sound like you stare at it and wonder
no no it's just like if you're eating
this then it's like you're also you're
it the garbages around it you're walking
around eating out of a garbage nest you
know we've had some dumb conversations
on this show pretty dumb this might be
one of the dumbest yeah yeah not the
dumbest but one of the dumb one of the
dumbest the peel is there for hygienic
reasons oh I did use it for that I know
but once it's off the banana it's
garbage now it's the dumbest yeah
let's see people are like we were there
the night it finally got to down let's
talk about closed-circuit you shot this
in London yes which was lovely I was
there last year for a few months and
great city of course and yes we shot
that and you enjoy your time there you
get to see the sights at all like
sometimes when you're in a city it's all
work work work work work when you're
making a film yeah you don't get to do
any sightsee did you get to go around
but a good thing about London is it's
just it's just there in front of you
isn't it it's like it's not a city you
need to go out of your way to enjoy
which is what I love about but I had a
great driver who was an interesting cat
he he just wouldn't be on the hook for
anything so if I asked him a question he
just didn't wanna be responsible for the
answer which was kind of interesting so
we'd be driving and it would be a
beautiful sunny day and I'd say nice day
today and he would say well supposedly I
mean the fact it could be I don't know I
don't know the sun shining it's it's 20
degrees that's a nice thing well
apparently it's what I say on a radio
you know and then I'd be like Hyde Park
is a really beautiful park well yeah
some say some say it is yeah one day I
remember we're driving past Buckingham
Palace not that I've got him this time I
said Buckingham Palace he was like today
it is yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
he's just covering his bases yeah I
admire heads yeah well we have a clip
from closed circuit what do we need to
know for this clip I play a barrister
who is defending someone in a terrorism
trial and I'm suspicious that mi5 have
links to the case so it's it's your
classic kind of thriller my partner my
characters a bit of a smartass and he's
very paranoid at this point in the movie
and he's uh he's in a cab ok let's take
a look at this clip from closed-circuit
it's actually quite convenient to be
under surveillance
well normally getting a tax it can be
quite difficult this time night
I see you using more than one taxi now
that's a good idea it's okay
apparently I'm paranoid
Wow
[Applause]